اللي ما نقدر نقوله موارد لكن نسبه ضئيله
جدا اول شيء كل الاحداث العالميه تعني
اعداد مستخدمين اكثر في مناصات التواصل
اجتماعيه فيعني تويتر اذا كان في وقت
اعتيادي قبل كاس العالم بشهر او شهرين يمر
في لحظه نمو بسيطه جدا مع كاس العالم
ومشاركه المنتخبات والحماس اللي يصير في
المشجعين في ناس اكبر راح تبدا تدخل من
النص وتسجل فيها وترى المعلوميه في تويتر
خلال الاشهر الماضيه صار فيه نمو جدا كبير
في المستخدمين يعني
عكس المتوقع طبعا في ناس تعزوا ذلك الى
الاحداث اللي صارت وفي ناس تتكلم منه ترى
الاخبار رجعت تطلع في كل مكان تراجعته
ساهم في شهره منصه فتويتر نفسها مبسوطه ان
في قنوات كثيره تتكلم عنها في جرس انت
متاكد من هذه المعلومات
بسيط جدا في اعداد مين الفاعلين في المنصه
يعني احنا ما نتكلم عن زياده مثلا نتكلم
عن 50% 60% لكن بنتكلم عن النسبه تشكل ترى
نسبه مقبوله جدا في تويتر لان تويتر كان
متوقع انه هيكون فيه انخفاض في اعداد
المستخدمين خاصه بعد الاستحواذ الى مماسك
على منصه لكن بعد استحواذ لهم ماسك صار في
نمو قد يكون نمو اعتيادي في المنصه وقد
تظهر همم المشاكل اللي تصير في المنصه
خلال الاشهر القادمه لكنه تكلم عن الفتره
الحاليه في نمو ومتوقع في فتره كاس العالم
يكون فيه نمو لانه مشجعين راح يدخلوا
لمناصه يستخدمونها لكن قد تواجه المنصه
مشاكل في تحديث الاخبار وغيرها لان تويتر
بالنهايه صارت في خدمات كثيره موجوده
عندها فلو دخلت مثلا على صفحه همم الاكسس
في تلقى اخبار كثيره موجوده وغيرها هذه هي
تدخل البشري بسيط جدا فقد يؤثر بشكل سلبي
ظهور الاخبار بشكل سريع بسبب قله الموظفين
اللي موجودين في تويتر في الفتره الحاليه
لكن نعم الفتره قد تتحسن الاجراءات قد
يكون الذكاء اصطناعي له دخل بشكل كبير لكن
لازم نعرف معلومه الى ماسكه مستحوذ على
منصه صحينا استغنى عن الموظفين لكن ترى
جاب موظفين واستعلام موظفين من شركات
الثانيه اعجاب شركه جاب موظفين من تسلا
جاب موظفين من شركات ثانيه وقال لهم تعال
احتاجكم موجودين في المنصه فهو اكيد
استغنى عن الموظفين لكن جاب اشخاص يثق في
انهم راح يحطون رؤاه بشكل اكبر في المنصه
من شركات التابع الثانيه لانهم ماسكه
ومستحوذ على منصه كانوا واضح بشكل جدي
كبير عنده رؤى مختلفه عند افكار مختلفه
عند حلم وطموح انه يطلق تطبيق الاكس اب
حسب ما يتكلم عنك
حاب يطلق تطبيق يكون هو تطبيق او احد
ويكون في كل الخدمات اللي يحتاجها تطبيق
واحد تدخل عليه يكون سوبر اب في كل خدمات
اللي انت تحتاجها خدمات ماليه دفع دردشه
منصه اجتماعيه اتكلم عن نسخه مقاربه من
انشات الصينيه لكن كنسخه امريكيه يكون
تويتر هو محطه التحول له همم هو حاب
يستفيد من اعداد مستخدمين تويتر همم
الكثير حول العالم ويطبق رؤيته ومنظوره في
الاكس اب